now for everybody here at The Voice
Blake Shelton is certainly more than a
co-worker he is a mentor he's a friend
somebody that we've all depended on
Blake Shelton wrapped his final episode
of NBC's The voice on Tuesday and
celebrated with an epic after party and
a big surprise
[Music]
an eyewitness tells E.T that Blake's
wife Gwen Stefani surprised her hubby by
making an appearance at the season 23
wrap party laying a big old kiss on him
we are just having the time of our lives
and we're just trying to save forever
every moment together the singer wasn't
able to attend the live taping due to a
prior commitment out of town but arrived
just in time to dance with her man to a
little Beyonce
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
she also shared a heartfelt message for
Blake in a pre-taped segment on the show
who would have thought this Orange
County girl and this country guy from
Oklahoma would find each other on the
set of the voice to find my soul mate
it's hard for me to even talk about it
without getting super emotional of
course Gwen and Blake met on the show in
2014 and went on to tie the knot in 2021
something he reflected on when ET
chatted with him leading up to his final
season on the show has it hit you yet
that your time on The Voice is coming to
an end I don't think it's really going
to hit me until
uh the the last episode it's probably
going to be an emotional night that last
night I mean my God it's been 23 see 12
years it's unbelievable it's to all the
life that's happened and I met my wife
on there just everything good that could
come from something like that it
I maxed it out 23 Seasons he has truly
changed people's lives the voice is
going to go on but Blake's Legacy will
be there forever I'm just so proud of
him I mean he's brought so much joy he's
so talented Gwen documented the hours
leading up to Blake's final taping where
are you going Blake we're going to The
Voice
really again so the last
time there he goes
on to the next and she shared a series
of throwback picks and videos on her
insta story say hi wow look at you
writing can't believe it's your last day
as for that wrap party
[Music]
it came one day after Gwen surprised
Blake with an intimate dinner on Monday
night where they enjoy chips salsa and
margaritas with friends including the
voice co-host Carson Daly at Casa Vega
in La it's Blake's last night on The
Voice I mean he has tomorrow but his
last Monday so we kind of surprised him
squid shared moments from the night on
social media he thinks that I'm having
some big party for you tomorrow and I'm
not so tonight was sort of a surprise I
saw on the schedule this morning that
you had a dinner tonight I said what's
this dinner you go
I don't know
well Gwen may not have pulled off the
surprise on Monday but she got him good
on Tuesday like have a great finale we
love you and I'll see you at home
[Music]